all right headed into first Gemini man
screening we're starting off with 3d
high frame rate ultra AVX d box I think
I know why as good as you
he is you alright I'm back at the
theater for my second showing of Gemini
man the the 2d 24 frames per second
version of this film so earlier today I
saw the 3d 60fps version and I don't I
have so much to say that I don't know
what I want to say and that's wobbling
again it like wobbles every time I move
and that's probably gonna be look
looking bad cuz 60 frames shows off all
the wobble my impressions of the 60fps
version are are not good this this movie
to me it looked incredibly cheap the the
60 frame the the high frame rate like
I've I kind of wish I could see the 120
version because I'm curious if it even
looks appreciably different to the 60
like if it's if it's perceptibly
different - to the 60fps I suspect not
maybe who knows it looked like a
made-for-tv movie and it looked like it
looked like a very special episode of
the sitcom of a sitcom it looked like it
looked like the episode of a sitcom
where they go to an amusement park or
the beach or you know it the action
scenes looked like they were lifted out
of Baywatch the the high frame rate just
takes a lot of the energy
out of some already like I don't know
like I get the impression I got the
impression that the action would look
pretty limp in in any version and so
we'll see what the we'll see what the 24
but like you know a lot like a lot like
glass in it like the the action is is
just kind of wet noodle it's it's limp
it's cold
very very like blandly shot very blandly
framed very blandly lit you know the the
120 FPS plus 3d requires so much light
that they're heavily reliant on on just
sunlight you know a lot of outdoor
locations in bright daylight and very
very little sculpting to the to the
light very little you know shaping of
shadows you kind of get the impression
that it's like they had very limited
access to a lot of the locations that
they were shooting on and so it's it's
that like okay well we can be like right
over here and we can only be here for
two days and so we kind of need to get
everything and so we just need to we
need to shoot efficiently and and that
ends up showing in the finished product
with the fact that it's like everything
is just kind of bare-bones they didn't
there's no there's no like real craft to
the way that anything anything is really
like shot and composed the way that
actors are blocked within the frame and
the way that they move relative to one
another is just it's it's very
utilitarian you know which again is like
these are the kind of hallmarks that you
end up seeing in like a made-for-tv
movie or you end up seeing in the beach
episode of a TV show like of a sitcom
that's shooting on tape and they're like
well we got all the actors
Disneyland and we've only got like two
days that we can be doing like outdoor
outdoor shots like we've got we've got
four hours in front of the castle and
that's it that's our window and we need
to get literally everything that we need
there you know done in that time and and
it just it ends up being like
fundamentally very unambitious very
uninteresting and there are a few like
you can tell the set pieces where they
did have time and they did put in like a
ton of energy and that shows and those
are like the most interesting parts of
the movie you know like there's there's
a big set piece towards the end of the
movie where the characters are avoiding
like mini gunfire and
[Music]
and that comes close to kind of showing
you like what 60 FPS could do but at the
same time I'm sitting there and I'm
watching it and and it's like okay I
already know what this looks like at 60
frames or at 120 frames or a 240 because
I've seen it at that framerate before in
every other action movie where they take
this they shoot it at that frame rate
and then they play it back at 24 and so
it's it's slow-mo like we have you see a
lot of high frame rate stuff in movies
anyway it's just it's all slo-mo and the
the current cinematic language of film
encompasses that and it come in it
encompasses a higher temporal resolution
in the form of slow motion which is a
lot more malleable there's just there's
more you can do with it there's you can
you can shape slow motion in a lot of
ways that you you can't necessarily
shape high frame rate because when you
raise your floor like that it's you just
you've you've got to go even higher and
higher in order to like get that stuff
and there's a very limited amount of
slow-mo in this which means that and
it's like and it's not much it's like
they went so they were shooting at 120
and they were maybe going up to like 160
200 maybe like there was one shot in
there where they went up to like 240
which gives you a 50% slowdown and now
the thing is is a 50% slowdown isn't
that much half speed is like barely
slow-mo for a lot of purposes like half
speed is what you would be shooting if
you were just kind of shooting like
product shots where where you wanted to
get like that extra kind of clarity and
stability out of the
out of I was slowing like you know out
of slowing it down like you know any any
camera shake is gonna get kind of
smoothed out by that and oh boy camera
shake like every jitter of the camera
registers as to its microscopic details
like you can feel all of the jitters and
not in a good way it's it's not
interesting it's not fun it's not
engaging that this really this movie is
not a good demonstration of the
strengths of 60fps and makes me wonder
if 60fps has or I shouldn't keep saying
60fps of high frame rate that it makes
me wonder if high frame rate has any
narrative strengths at all and I want it
to because I think it's an interesting
tool I think I think there is potential
for high frame rate it just takes the
right people to figure it out and at the
moment having seen the high frame rate
version of Gemini man this is not that
you know if if like Michael Bay we're
doing high frame rate or Zack Snyder
we're doing high frame rate I think this
would be a very different story at the
very least it would be lit better it
would not look like it would not look
like made-for-tv and this is it was some
of the worst 3d I've seen in quite a
while the grade the the color the color
grade is just bad and I don't just mean
like just really limp it's lame there
was a whole bunch of scenes super
overexposed and they were like they had
these really wide latitudes and they had
a lot of like really like wide dynamic
range shots you know it's like oh we're
indoors but you can resolve the stuff
that's outside the window and we didn't
put you know we didn't put gels on
the window like look you can actually
like hold all that and say okay like
that's kind of neat you like that's
technically interesting but it's it's
not shaped and it's not really used well
it's like whatever but then there's a
bunch of shots where it's just like it's
on the border of being blown out but
then they've like brought it back down
but they didn't and I'm wondering if
this had to do with like the 3d version
that I was seeing like is this just an
artifact of like the 2k 3d 60fps I will
I see this same problem in the 2d
version I don't know we're gonna see
going into it but like they so they're
up at clipping and then they just kind
of took it and like lowered it but so
the clipping point you know you're pure
white things that are approaching that
don't get dimmer the white just goes
down and it ends up so instead of having
instead of everything going up to pure
white it just goes up to slightly below
pure white and so pure white is just
dimmer and that might have been an
artifact of the of the 3d like they
might have been clipping out and then
like you take that and add the dimming
of the glasses and it ends up looking
muddy you know I don't know yet we'll
see when I've got something to to
compare it to so a thing that I'm
wondering is like is it going to look as
cheap at 24 frames 2d like without the
glasses without the high frame rate is
it going to look as cheap is is the is
it going to look as boring is the
lighting going to be as uninteresting is
the framing going to be as uninteresting
is the blocking going to be as
uninteresting and and maybe I'll
actually be able to talk about the movie
as a story which I don't know like it
completely bounced off me and it seemed
to bounce off like the the entire
audience that I was with earlier today
we it wasn't a full theatre but it
wasn't an empty theatre okay was a
mostly empty theatre I saw it in a
mostly empty theater earlier today but
there were other people there
and I don't remember if there was a
single like comedy relief moment or like
tense moment or just like wow moment
that got any kind of audible reaction
from the audience I don't remember any
comic relief moment I don't I don't even
know if there was comedy in this movie
and howdy oh wait no there were some
jokes at the end and they felt like a
sitcom which was really bizarre because
the end of this movie up until like the
closing scene is pretty grim and like
and you're if you're using high frame
rate you're doing so to try to create
reality or hyper reality but this is not
doing anything with hyper reality it's
neither realistic enough to to exploit
the reality element of that you know
make you feel like you're you're
watching something that like maybe
actually happened like 60 FPS is maybe
going to be like best suited for you
know found footage or something like
that like a horror film you know I think
I think there's a lot of room in that
like if you're trying to exploit the
fact that things look real and if you're
trying to exploit the fact that like so
one of the quirks of high frame rate is
that the higher your frame rate goes the
closer things look to reality the
problem is with with narrative film than
is that reality is not necessarily your
constructed reality or the reality
you're attempting to construct the
reality is a bunch of actors standing
around acting at each other and you know
you see this a lot in in Billy Lenz long
halftime walk if you watch the high
frame rate version of that where there's
like all of the extras in these these
crowd shots you become keenly aware of
the fact that they're extras who are
miming
crowd actions like and like you know
they're moving their hands a lot and
they're just trying to look busy and
they're pointing at things in ways that
like nobody does in real life and it's
like okay it looks fake
you look like actors you have exposed
the reality of the fact that your movie
is a bunch of actors pretending to do
stuff and you know that's that's a thing
that you need to like incorporate or
accept or or overcome and and Billy Lin
does not manage to do that and Gemini
man does a better job but doesn't do a
good job and you know on the other end
would be like you're using it to
construct hyper reality and this is
where I think like this is kind of why I
say like I want to see like a Michael
Bay or a Zack Snyder do something with
it where you're going you're going all
in on just absurdity you're you're
escalating to just this this comical
degree and you're constructing a world
that is so divorced from reality that
that it becomes its own substance and I
think if you're going that far then like
who knows like what'll what happens if
you then take that and raise it to you
know raise the frame rate on it
and I think that would be maybe where
you would you would see something
interesting coming out of that where
you're constructing like you're you're
not just like presenting hyper reality
you are constructing a a reality worthy
of being hyper real because otherwise
you're just you're you're calling
attention to all the stuff and Billy
Lynn had a lot of this fakeness like
tons of problems with this fakeness and
a lot of also problems with
the fact that it's it's it's limited by
its budget you know these are these are
both expensive movies but that expense
seems to be very unevenly distributed
it's all in post-production it's all in
camera Department and post-production
and like none of it isn't lighting none
of it isn't sets none of it is in you
know getting that key thing that you
need you know you watch Billy Lin and
it's very obvious that you know like
Beyonce is there and it's super obvious
that it's not Beyonce because they're
always showing the back of her head in
this really obvious way which when
combined with the fact that the movie
already looks and feels like a sitcom
just becomes even more comical because
now you're looking at something that
already looks like a sitcom and is now
using a sitcom trope of like oh here's
this the gang meets a famous person but
we can't actually afford the famous
person to like show up and shoot our you
know 22 minute sitcom so it's just it's
always the back of their head you know
the the gang meets Elton John but it's
just it's it's just some actor kind of
dressed like Elton John with a wig on
and they walk into frame you always see
them from behind and you know it's it's
using that trick and it uses it multiple
times very obviously and it's like okay
this plays in a sitcom because a sitcom
is this cheap thing and it's principally
about like banter and character
interactions and a little bit of
slapstick doesn't really play for your
war movie about PTSD doesn't really play
for your action film about
I don't know what this movies about I
don't know what Gemini man is about its
Will Smith want a fast government
assassin wants to retire and his [ __ ]
ex boss sends his clone to kill him
that's it
you know there's there's not really
there's not really a message
so anyway I'm gonna go get some snacks
and let's go see Gemini man for a second
time hello and welcome to my latest
tutorial how to grade like Gemini man so
we've got this footage from New York
it's pretty wide in terms of its dynamic
range but you can see over here on the
scopes that whoever shot it did a good
job at protecting the highlights so
we've we've got a lot to work with here
now as always the first thing we're
gonna do is slap a LUT on it so just
just find just find your favorite LUT
and slap it in there there we go now
since this is the Gemini man look we're
going for we will naturally be
exhibiting in 3d which means we need
colors to really pop pop pop to make up
for the 3d glasses so add a node and
just grab that saturation and crank it
right on up and you know what let's do
it again just add another node and just
keep on turning it up just crank it just
crank it right on up a good rule of
thumb here is that if the audience can
look at a color without experiencing
physical discomfort then you've got some
room to turn it up okay so now that that
is painful to look at we check our
waveform and uh-oh we're definitely
clipping out and are no longer DCI
compliant for exhibition so how about we
just add another note and let's just
let's let's just you know clamp that off
and yeah that's you know what that's all
all you really need to do to recreate
the deeply uncomfortable experience of
watching a substantial chunk of
professionally made film Gemini man all
right I'm out of the movie
I am I made it about halfway through the
the 4dx version with the giant like the
giant motion sim seats and the the scent
wafting throughout the theater which
never failed to smell like anything more
than the generic idea of scent it didn't
it was a you would just
okay so 40 X ok okay so 40 X is is a new
thing it's part of the whole like value
added cinema experience along with
things like 3d and and high frame rate
and dynamic seed movements roll heave
and pitch with the on-screen action
water effects spray through the theater
wind effects recreate a turbulent storm
or the sensation of speed lightning
flashes just inches away scent adds a
new dimension of realism fog adds drama
to the seen bubbles bring a buoyant
atmosphere to life a tickler adds
vibration to your legs for a full body
experience and floating snow adds a
dreamlike effect with over 20 different
effects for DX is the movie experience
you just have to see and feel to believe
see your next movie in 40 x only at
Cineplex ok battery died so 40 X is part
of the whole like it's part of the value
added cinema experience along with 3d
high frame rate all of this other stuff
basically things gimmicks that they're
trying to
that can't be really easily or
affordably replicated at home and are
thus something that you kind of have to
go to the theater to experience a
tickler at sly bration to your legs.i I
don't know I ranted about this whole
bunch before I realize the battery was
dead and they're just they're just
neither like it's not it's not awful
like you know that motion sim experience
but like it really did not suit this
movie and wasn't particularly
interesting and like okay so like the
the 40x
you're you're in a bench of like four
seats that all move together and that's
that's kind of interesting you know in
kind of what it can do and the range of
motion as a result is is a little more
extreme you know it's also more precise
like the motions are less less jittery
they're more fluid but they're also just
more extreme as a baseline where where
the D box seats like you have of
individual control on like how intense
you want your seat to be in so like you
can actually like shut it off and if
it's just you know too obnoxious you
could just you could just turn it off
the real problem with the forty X so the
the seat motion got tiring the sense
never smelt like anything in at all like
they just smelled like the idea of scent
the real problem was that they have a
strobe or I guess what is supposed to be
several strobes or or you know at least
two different strokes up at the top that
that go off for things like lightning
strikes gunfire stuff like that you know
basically anything that would be in
screen flashed the strobe flashes and
enhances the experience but like I don't
I don't know if the system just sucks or
or if there was something broken about
this this theater because only the
strobe on my right-hand side so the
right-hand side of the theater only that
strobe was going off and so it was just
constantly like only ever coming in like
one side and one strobes are annoying as
hell at the best of times and then
having a strobe only like strobe one
side of your vision is is immeasurably
worse and so after I made it about
halfway through the movie and it was
just like no more and went out and
talked to guest services and switched
into the IMAX 4k screening that started
a little bit after the one that I was
the the the 40 X one that I was in so I
have seen all or part of three different
formats now going it and there's
problems with all of them so going into
the 4k version was actually kind of
really really interesting one it was
just it took me a while just to adjust
of being stationary again and just be
like enjoying watching a movie in just a
reclining seat and and the motion
cadence is at least ordinary and and
things look I don't want to say normal
because they didn't but you know you're
not being overwhelmed but but the higher
resolution so jumping up from 2k to 4k
all of a sudden the movie now has a high
enough resolution that you can see like
the edges on power windows in the grade
there's like fringing around characters
faces against the sky juniors look like
just the the a lot more flaws are are
obvious in 4k that we're actually pretty
well hidden in in 2k like you you start
to really notice that like the his nose
isn't right like the upper lip like just
kind of this whole area like the upper
lip and the nose like it doesn't it
doesn't behave properly and that's
really obvious actually at the the end
of the movie when a second jr. is like
dying and the soundtrack has this really
like labored breathing but but his nose
like the the nostril flare
there's no nostril flare and so like
even though there's this like really
heavy breathing nose breathing like
you're not getting that labored kind of
tension in the face and like the so the
face just looks overly static and you
know yeah I mean but like creating a CG
person like photo-realistic human is
like really hard and you know credit for
coming as far as they have but it's just
ironic that this movie that is
fetishizing technology to such a degree
looks worse at its higher-end versions
that the higher you go the more flaws
appear because you know if if they had
focused on on finishing this for a 2k
delivery like if that had been their
primary delivery with the tech pipeline
that they have in in you know like that
juniors rendering like it would look
amazing like it I mean it does look
pretty good but you know it would it
would blow everything away if they had
been able to focus on like okay we're
going to like maximize all of the things
that are going to be visible in a 2k
delivery and use
the fact that we're delivering at a
lower temperature
just actual you know geometric
resolution pixel resolution use that to
to hide imperfection and allow
imagination to take over allow the
audience's brain to to take over and do
a lot more heavy lifting with with
guessing and filling things in and and
whatnot and it would work so much better
but but nothing nothing is going to make
up for the fact that like it's just a
boring movie and is is just really
underwhelming and limp and ineffective
confusing not particularly interesting
at the end of the day the critical flaw
here is the film itself it's it's none
of the technology you know the the
technology at best like distracts from
it maybe but it is is ultimately just a
really underwhelming film so going to
the going to the 24 FPS version a lot of
the problems that I identified in the
high frame rate version still exist
in terms of like the the blocking the
framing camera movement acting blind
delivery the script itself it it no
longer looks it still looks like TV it's
it's just that it looks like an episode
of 24 or homeland instead of looking
like an episode of full house the grade
it's it's less muddy less muddy than it
was in 3d but it was pretty much what I
was guessing which was that it is it's
really over compressed in the highlights
really oversaturated in a lot of ways
and that like that has been like brought
down and then you add the 3d glasses on
top of it and that gave it this muddy
look but even seeing it in without the
3d glasses like it's still like the
highlights are just really squashed in a
lot of places and the the saturation is
cranked so high like probably to
compensate for 3d glasses like that
you're watching if you watch the 2d
version you were probably not like I was
probably not watching a version that had
been properly prepared for 2d
presentation and it's just been kind of
tweaked you know like they hadn't gone
through and given it like a careful
grade they had just bends like a we
start with the 3d version and compensate
for the glasses and then pull it back by
five percent and ship it for the 2d
version and and it looks bad I mean it
already looked bad with 3d glasses on it
does not look good in either version
it's so compressed in the highlights
it's so just like it ends up being flat
and washed out and and in a lot of
places so if you if you raise colors way
too high like if you raise the
saturation way too high so that they
come up like either clipping or right
under clipping and then you kind of
lower everything you create this odd
optical effect where something is
simultaneously dull looking but way too
bright because it's kind of both
same time like so it looks overexposed
but the literal luminance value is below
the point that you would expect it to be
and and so it messes with the brain it
just it looks weird yeah the all the
outdoor stuff and there is a lot of
outdoor stuff because it relies on it
just does not look good and there's a
lot of there's a lot of really just like
bland day for night shooting because
again their shoot like they need just so
much light for these these cameras that
they're using and shooting at 120fps
that you know they they can't actually
shoot in the dark they can't actually
shoot at night and like lighting
convincingly at night they do it a
couple times in like City locations
where they're able to like actually
shoot at night and just use you know
lamps and stuff like that to to get the
light level that they need but then
there's just a ton of stuff like out on
the boats that's all it's all day for
night with a sky replacement and looks
cheap doesn't doesn't look great doesn't
look like the kind of thing that you
know is up to
the the conceptual level of what you
would expect from a movie where they're
like our gonna shoot it just this absurd
frame rate and we're gonna do it in 3d
as well and we're going we're gonna go
all out on these two things and and cut
everything else in order to accommodate
that and that's that was Billie Lynn
that's Gemini man there's a whole thing
with there's just some bad editing like
just really sloppy coverage of
conversations this was in Billy Lynn as
well and it happened again in Gemini man
where you'll have like three or four
characters talking to each other and and
like I lines and stuff will just go
wherever the the angles of the
characters are being covered from will
just flip around the the axis of action
is wherever they want it to be for any
given shot you'll get you'll get a
number of shots we're like characters
like stare directly into the lens
oh my light went out so you get a whole
bunch of moments where characters are
either like looking directly into the
lens or even worse they have an eye line
that is that is like right right beside
the lens and so they're they're not
they're they're not looking into the
camera but they're not really looking
away from the camera either and and and
when it's on this when it's when that
image is on this giant screen that
difference is is really noticeable and
really unsettling and what else haven't
I talked about yet I mean the story
itself IRA dimension was is limp and
bland
and amazingly oh it amazingly manages to
suck any sort of like philosophical
tension out of the idea of
like cloning that Will Smith confronts
his own clone but they treated they
treat it so realistically in the sense
that like his clone is like 23
so his clone was like made 23 years ago
and is growing up you know in in real
time like a normal human being and isn't
you know sci-fi accelerated growth super
soldier or anything like that so if you
want clones a deck you know 20 years
from now you got to start growing him
now and the the side effect of that is
the the reality kind of sets in of like
oh well a clone really isn't that
different from a child like from from
just having a kid and and that even if
Will Smith's clone is genetically
identical to him the relationship really
is pretty damn close to just being
father-son like age difference was
between them and you know there's
there's this really funny line that
shows up in the trailer where junior
says you made a person out of another
person and it's like yeah man that's
genetics that's how babies work like
that's just that's what a baby is and it
is it being really funny and also just
like I guess this is the thing I'll go
out on the the the trailer presents a
far more interesting story than the
movie itself actually is because the
trailer is principally told from juniors
point of view so if you watch the
trailer you're given the impression that
you're watching a movie about a kid
who's who's like this rate born and
raised assassin who's being sent out on
this hit and then he realizes
that his job is is to kill the person
that he's being cloned from and that's
the the opposite of the of the story as
its told in in the actual movie because
it's the opposite because you're you're
not really you you don't really in the
film get a point where jr. really
grapples with like the fact that he's a
clone and when they try to do it in the
scene or it's like you made a person of
another person it's there's not really
an existential crisis to that the the
the bigger existential crisis the bigger
the bigger crisis in that conflict is
really just the fact that he was lied to
about his parentage because they've made
being a clone so bland that it's it's no
different than if the the antagonist was
like oh yeah we just stole you from a
maternity ward and then told you that
your parents died in a car crash and I
will you lied to me like I have parents
out there you know it's basically the
same as that he's more hung up on the
fact that he was told he's an orphan
than any sort of identity crisis of
being a clone because again in the world
that they've constructed there really
isn't an identity crisis to be had about
being a clone cuz it's not that
different than just being someone's
child and also like it's worth noting
that they they raised the fact that a
clone would require a surrogate mother
and nary a word of that is ever
mentioned again she's never brought up
she's never identified no one cares
about her or who she is or what her role
in all of this was or what happened to
her what happened to the woman who was
involved in this illegal human cloning
super-soldier program what happened to
the rest of the women involved in the
illegal secret super soldier cloning
program because there's there's jr.
number two who has been genetically
edited to not feel pain or fear or
whatever and and none of that and the
other interesting thing about the about
the trailer which I have now finally
seen after after seeing three versions
of this film I finally went and watched
the trailer and the grade and the
trailer is better the trailer actually
makes use of a lot of slow-mo that
doesn't exist in the movie itself which
makes sense that if you're cutting a
trailer and somebody has basically has
handed you you know a box full of 120fps
footage it's all footage that if you're
if you're cutting a 24 FPS trailer you
can do whatever you want with it
and like any any subtle or extreme
amount of slow-mo you want to create is
all just gonna look buttery smooth and
so there's a bunch of shots in the
trailer that are slowed down a
conventional amount there's a
conventional amount of time warping
going on with them in order to like you
know amplify the intensity of the of the
moment and you know it's it's not
extreme but it's there and the trailer
also does include the few V like three
shots in the actual movie that do have
slow-mo those are included in the
trailer as well at basically the amount
of slow-mo that you would see if you go
see it in theaters but then there's a
bunch of other shots that have the
slow-mo added to them because they could
and it's it's really interesting to see
the trailer make better use of the tools
for cinematic storytelling than the
movie that it is pulling from I know
that's not unusual for a trailer to be
better than a movie but it's just it's
it's interesting for those technical
tools to be better utilized and for for
that hundred and twenty FPS footage that
they grabbed to be better utilized and
also it's really fascinating to me that
all of the high frame rate films to this
point I think Billy Lin is the only one
that has released a high frame rate
trailer there might be a high frame rate
trailer for Gemini man out there I
didn't find it on a cursory search but I
mean searching for movie trailers get
re-uploaded so many times in so many
different places that finding a specific
version can be challenging so there
might be one out there but I did not
find it and it is certainly not the one
that is surfaced when you do an initial
search it's it's not the first thing to
come up so they have not done if if high
frame rate is an element of the movie
that they're trying to emphasize they've
done a bad job of emphasizing that by
not making it easy for audiences to find
and engage with and this is all just
this is a bigger problem with high frame
rate as a whole in in a cinematic scope
and I'll get more into that later
but I feel like that's at least 80% of
what I want to say about Gemini man
so to close this out here's that bit
with the tickler again a tickler ATS
vibration to your legs for a full body
experience
he've with the on-screen action